I think the idea of a Scandinavian
entitles lead to have a mill
democratized and Monica and my argument
is simple.
If we are to be a modern country in the
21st century,
part of various global alliances and
trading blocks and so on,
we have to have institutions that match
that Melbourne position,
fortune as a half grown stented
democracy.
We take pride in being the mother of
parliaments and yet we still have a lot
of our constitution.
This institution which is hereditary,
backward looking medieval.
Now.
Some of the PR is pretty good.
The forthcoming now reading will excite
people and be no doubt there will be a
big outpouring of jury on the day,
but underneath that is the hidden wiring
in the constitution where there are road
Paris exercise both by the Mahler
Kendall said by the ministers.
There is a very obscure system of
financing the royal family which the
public doesn't understand and isn't
privy to it.
Secrets.
There's the question of the Commonwealth
and why the Queen is head of all these
other countries,
a form of colonial countries out of the
question of the Church of England and
why it is that the queen or her
successes are in charge of the
Protestant church in the United Kingdom,
so under these issues need to be
ventilated as we move to the road is the
perfect opportunity.
It shouldn't come as a threat to the
monarchy to have people to say it needs
to be modernized.
Indeed,
the only genuine world tradition is
change.
Real real wisdom requires modernization
as a whole minutes.
To summarize your
21 century,
a
science fiction,
a festival of a bitch is an example of
democracy around the world and in
particular on the culture down and
it's
got
good shots to from the monarchy.
He's not under his jurisdiction a pass
on the separation between the power and
for my interview view,
the monarchy most change by in and spoke
to him.
He's not a politician.
It's not.